what fraction of this circle is shaded
red
so let's see this circle is divided into
one two three four five six seven eight
equal parts and of those eight equal
parts seven are shaded red so we can say
that seven out of eight are shaded red
and this isn't how we've traditionally
seen fractions when we've written them
when we've written them we've written it
like this
we have written
seven
over eight are shaded red and actually
let me do it in that color although i
don't have an exact let me get closer to
an actual red color so we could like
literally say seven
out of
out of them we need like a gray color
was
was non-shaded seven out of a total
eight are shaded red
r shaded
red that's how we're used to seeing it
but sometimes or usually when we type it
in there's no way to write the seven
over the eight so instead instead we
write seven over eight
over eight are shaded red or seven out
of eight so let's do that go back to
what we were doing so seven out of eight
or shaded red let's check our answer
let's do two more of these
what fraction of the bar is shaded red
so the bar has one two three four five
six seven eight nine equal sections and
eight of them are shaded red so we can
say that eight out of nine are shaded
red or eight ninths or eight over nine
let's do one more
what fraction of this circle is shaded
red so we have one two three four five
six seven eight nine equal sections did
i count that right let me count again
one two three four five six seven eight
nine equal sections and of those one two
three four five six seven are shaded red
so seven out of nine or seven ninths are
shaded red